flashback Trump said you know I just
found out that Democrats are funding
Nikki Haley's campaign I hear that
Democrats are contributing to run a
disantis let me uh play the clip for you
guys I just found out that Democrats are
funding Nikki Haley's campaign I hear
that Democrats are contributing to Ronda
sanus or Ronda sanct demonius to Rond
desantis's campaign I I got to stop you
there Trump it's it's D swamp this okay
the swamp this was always the best name
but he went with the Sanctus whatever
but the conspiracy theory now I suppose
I don't think it's actually conspiracy
the I think it's a fact we know for fact
that Nikki Haley is getting support from
Democrats many of the voters that are
coming out and voting for her in Iowa
that voted for her in Iowa are liberal
individuals and we have the proof it's
in the pudding the Iowa caucus results
Trump lost only one Precinct and it was
by one vote actually it looks like he
may have reclaimed it so this was uh
where do we have Johnson County oh okay
no no Johnson County look at this
they're not even showing it anymore
Johnson County is the only County that
went for Nikki Haley by one vote and as
it's pointed out to us this is the urban
liberal college area so it's not
surprising that's what happening but
that would mean that many people are
coming out for Nikki Haley they're in
Liberal areas they are liberal Democrat
voters and then we have this from The
New York Times in Iowa Nikki Haley has
the attention of Democrats and
Independence Haley has attracted the
interest of non-republican who say
they'll caucus for her as Rivals
attacker for an insufficiently
conservative message this is the play
ladies and gentlemen we were
speculating how are they going to get
Joe Biden out of the race Joe Biden
would have to suffer some injury get
sick but then it it he's passed the
point at which the Democrats can have a
primary so then people said it won't
happen a strategist for JP Morgan said
no he'll he will drop out uh due to a
medical issue and my response does it
make that's actually smart it allows
them to appoint a nominee by passing a
primary preventing a burning Sanders
situation V is smarter he act he pointed
out and I believe he's correct he said
no The Establishment play is the primary
it's Nikki Haley the Deep state will
stop at nothing to remove Donald Trump
and when they do it's going to be Nikki
Haley versus Ron DeSantis and Nikki will
win and that's how they're going to take
back the system and we get more Wars we
get World War III I think that's
actually what's happening right now when
you look at the Democrats voting for
Haley the New York Times is saying it
outright to Nikki Haley they realized we
cannot win a general election against
Donald Trump however Donald Trump will
struggle to win Blue State primaries if
they if Democrats come out and vote for
Nikki Haley so this she's Hillary
Clinton you of course you can no you
can't you can't do that in every primary
yes you can well you'd have to change
your some of them you'd have to change
your voter registrations that far in
advance yep and so these people have
been planning this for a year look look
the said they'll stop at nothing and we
can't look back on this in 2025 and say
how did we not see this coming he's
correct so how many votes do they need
to beat Donald Trump Nikki Haley got
what nine delegates let me let me what
is it she got eight delegates eight she
got eight delegates in Iowa she's behind
Ronda Sanz but she is polling in uh in
the high double digit or I should say uh
uh near as high as Trump in New
Hampshire and it is speculated these are
Democrat voters that have switched their
parties this is this is it I mean in New
Hampshire you don't have to be switch
your party you can be an independent
Democrat vote in the primary right and
so for four places where you need to be
a registered party member like in a
caucus you just do it in advance super
easy and then there's states with open
primaries what I think we're seeing are
actually rather fascinating is the end
of the democratic party when when they
realize you can't beat Donald Trump in a
general election their only plan their
only path is to beat him in a primary
it's actually kind of scary if you think
about what comes after this if there if
the general election doesn't matter CU
it's Joe Biden with no support the
Republican Party becomes the single
party rule in this country and while
many people may may say oh but that's
great we like Republicans we'd rather
they win than Democrats no but you don't
understand it's Democrats weaseling
their way into the Republican party as
their only means of stealing power and
then instead of having general elections
we have whoever our president's going to
be is going to be solely based on who
wins the Republican primary
yeah I mean I think it's getting pretty
desperate uh on honestly on both sides
of the aisle right there are a ton of
people who do not want Trump to be the
nominee they don't outnumber the people
who want him to be the nominee but the
tactics are there when ASA Hutchins
dropped out one of the the pieces that I
read when I was researching for my
article was uh the recommendation from a
Republican strategist that he endorsed
Nikki Haley who he shares more votes
with you know he's this long-term
Governor from Arkansas uh I think there
are going going to be sort of moments
until the end until her campaign is over
where people are trying to say well if
just the right people and she got some
states we can still make this happen
there's still a way to deny Trump and I
think that's ultimately uh denying
reality at this point yeah I think you
have something interesting Tim because I
saw a colleague a friend from The
Hamptons an older gentleman AE Sab and
he was on Neil Cavuto last week I was
just thinking about that and he said the
interesting we're doing a fundraiser for
Nikki at the end of the month and a lot
of Democrats are coming yeah he said
believe it or not a number of it is
coming from Democrats Democratic
fundraisers and they're doing a big
fundraiser in New York for Nikki hiy why
would why would they join Nikki Hy
Democrats and what's what are Nikki H's
positions proar proar don't call illegal
immigrants criminals right register with
the government before you com out
anything online s to social media y she
yeah she's uh she's definitely sort of
the the Hillary Clinton of this campaign
she's even running on you know I'm a
woman elect me that that's a
qualification somehow and she likes to
talk about her high heeled shoes none of
this I think if you were really a
candidate you wouldn't have to like you
being one would be like a fun benefit
right but it wouldn't be the ma major
tenant of your campaign this uh ad
impacted the study and they were talking
about uh the top themes that each of the
candidates during their ad spend have
because Republicans have spent like $230
million so far and Trump is talking
about illegal drug trafficking he's
talking about the Border he's talking
about policy talking about trade and
both DeSantis and U Nikki Haley are
talking about China which you know fair
and they're talking about character
which is just code for they're trying to
say we're better than Trump and I can't
even remember the last thing they talked
about because it's just so irrelevant
they are trying to separate themselves
from Trump and Trump is the one setting
the pace for policy the thing is Trump
is able to run on a lot of the same
policies and ideas that he did in 2016
because he had four years he did a lot
of really good things Biden took over
literally reversed everything on purpose
and now it's like oh we're still we're
back here now we have to redo it even
look at the situation with the uh the
hooes in Yemen right you had um you had
Trump when he was leaving office
classified the houthis as terrorists at
the day he came into office Biden
reversed that and he said no they're not
a they're not terrorists and the reason
that he reversed it was for apparently
humanitarian reasons which is the same
reason we're throwing money at Gaza
right so that Hamas can Massacre people
again um but now he's talking now
Biden's talking about oh I better make
the houthis classify them as terrorists
and it's like they've been terrorists
this whole time you know so he literally
came into office reversed all the good
things Trump did made a whole bunch out
of spite did a whole bunch of really bad
things and in terms of the border wall
reversed the concept of the border wall
and then left all the equipment and
supplies just sitting there rotting
waiting for nothing thing you know with
people climbing over it and then had to
like re restart up the border wall
anyway even though now that's you know
irrelevant now because it's humanitarian
too late they're going to try and spin
it so that like whatever they did was
the correct thing to do but so Trump is
able to run on the same stuff that
brought him into office in the first
place the same reasons now on to the
good things Joe Biden has
done oh it's very quiet now he's got a
33% approval rate nothing it's rough can
we can we think of anything come on
let's be as nice as we can um nothing
can't he's been Pro U pardoning people
for some drug drug offenses which like
depending on your stance on that that
could be perceived as a good thing um
he's given up some of the best memes of
of the day age the marijuana pardoning
thing was DB because there's nobody in
prison at the federal level Federal
exactly for possession when when all the
rambunctious left uh progressives were
anti-israel he stood up a little bit but
I just read recently he hasn't talked to
Biby uh the prime minister in like three
or four weeks incredible being being
wishy-washy is like what's a good thing
he's done being like halfway there is
not a good thing it's like well he was
like tepid here no no no what was he
good on I'm gen I'm trying to be honest
like can we I want to think of something
because I feel like if you it's too easy
to be like everything he did is awful
and he's terrible like I want to be you
know you know analytical and say like
well maybe this was good but it's very
hard well I I I remember during Trump's
presidency so when he won in you know
when he won in 2016 I remember thinking
okay like I didn't vote for Trump in
2016 but he's the president I'm going to
support the president and I'm going to
watch what he does and see you know see
what his policies are and go from there
and then every like he kept coming out
with policies I was like that's good
well that's good that's good and with
Biden I did the same thing I was like I
didn't vote for Biden you know I wisened
up I voted for Trump I didn't vote for
Biden and I I thought okay well I'll you
know I'll watch I'll see what he does
and everything that he did every
executive order I kept reading the
executive orders this is terrible idea
this is this is destructive this is
destroying everything um I can't think
I've been tracking his his time in
office since he took over and I can't
think of a single good thing that I that
he did where I was like oh that's good
I'm glad he did that I can't think of
anything at yeah I mean even with Obama
I remember you know he made some efforts
to uh encourage private investment
investment in space travel and I was
like that's but was Hunter Biden on the
board of the space travel company it's
always the question I mean it's re it's
it's to me not a good sign that there is
a president that we can't off the bat be
like this one seems okay well look at
what he did on his first day in office
right he pushed Equity he pushed weird
gender stuff he reversed the border wall
right he Declassified the houthis as
terrorists he did so many terrible
things and he said during his first
campaign speech a couple weeks ago you
know the the Republicans are all focused
on the past and then all he did was talk
about January 6 but that's actually been
the theme of his administration the
whole time I mean he has everyone is
saying oh Trump is saying revenge and
he's going to do whatever but actually
it's Democrats who have been acting out
of spite right the fact that he reversed
his first day in office reversed a ton
of trump policies just because Trump did
them to prove to his base that Trump is
bad and then let us all suffer the
consequences of his you know spite is
not good what what out of the two of
them who talks more about the future and
who harps on the past non-stop the
Democrats harp on the past thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at Tim cast.com for
uncensored membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time